so why is it that Indian immigrants from
India the country and the ethnic group
of Indians in America are crushing every
other ethnic group in America not by
five percent not by ten percent by
twenty percent in income we have stats
on their divorce rates against everybody
else we have stats on how they raise
their kids we have stats on how they put
their kids in certain majors over other
Majors it's just mind-boggling and
everybody else is going to learn a ton
about how Indians raise their kids
[Music]
thank you
all right so if you get value from this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
income is one of the ways to measure
who's more successful than others okay
this is according to the U.S Census
Bureau where Indian Americans rank
amongst other ethnic groups if you look
at this chart here this is 2018 Indians
all the way at the top at 120 000 income
Taiwanese is number two they're ahead of
them by nearly 25 24 Chinese third
Japanese fourth and it's Pakistani
Filipino Indonesian Korean Cambodian
Monk and then Vietnamese and look where
white Americans are at 65 000 Indians
make 55 more thousand dollars per year
than white Americans by the way white
Americans you're trying to go to four
days a week work week try convincing
an immigrant coming from India Taiwan
China Japan Pakistan Filipino Indonesian
Korean Cambodian Persian Hmong
Vietnamese trying to convince them to
only work four days a week not their
kids who are born here maybe and they've
been Americanized try convincing an
immigrant to only work four days a week
they will laugh at you the whole purpose
of coming to America is that they can
work as much as they want it's called
free enterprise but let's kind of take a
deep dive with some of these other stats
Indian population living in poverty
amongst percentage-wise with Americans
all Americans roughly 13 of Americans
live in poverty all agents it's ten
percent look at Indians only six percent
of all Indians in America live in
poverty now let's look at education what
percentage of them have bachelor's
degrees what percentage of percentage of
them have Masters or mbas and what
degrees they have look at this year in
2021 80 of Indian immigrants over 25
years old or older reported having at
least a bachelor's degree versus only a
third of all foreign born and U.S born
adults again eighty percent versus 33
percent 80 percent of 25 and older have
a degree for your degree 49 of Indian
immigrants adults have at least a
graduate or professional degree in 2021
compared to 15 of foreign born and 13 of
U.S born nearly four times of U.S porn
is what they have now what do they major
in let's kind of go a little bit deeper
into that one lots of people waste money
on degrees that have no amount of high
paying jobs most people agree that you
plan on going to college you need to
major in stem to make it a good
investment but Indian Americans abide by
this it's like a religion STEM Science
technology engineering and math look at
the chart here on what they major in at
the top you see the blue engineering 36
percent then it's math in computer
science 35 then that 10 at the top you
see it business management so they're
intentional about what areas they're
gonna go major in now let's go even a
little bit deeper than this on how they
measure amongst other ethnic groups this
is according to the U.S Census Bureau if
you look at the top right you'll see all
immigrants it's a darker blue you'll see
Indian immigrants it's a lighter blue
and then you'll see U.S born okay
furthest to the left is management
business science art occupations look
who's in the middle
79 of Indian immigrants versus 43
percent of U.S foreign versus 37 percent
of all immigrants they major in
management business and science look at
service occupation they're the lowest by
at five percent U.S is 15 and all the
other immigrants 21 they're like no
you're not going to major in service
when you go into this look at sales and
office occupation 10 15 21 National
resource Constitution maintenance
occupation they're one percent it's
almost as if you do go and major in that
you're going to get a lot of pop out
from your parents there but it's a one
percent eight percent for US foreign
twelve percent from all immigrants then
production transportation material
moving 6 13 15. look they're not
interested in that you know what they're
interested in management business
science is what they're interested in
they want to do stem so obviously this
leads to them making a lot of money but
let's look at business are they start up
entrepreneurs do they do they produce
billionaires I don't know let's take a
look so here's what it looks like
according to Oxford academic Indian
immigrants represent one percent of the
U.S population but eight percent of the
founders of high-tech companies and one
third of Technology startups in Silicon
Valley one percent of total US
population eight percent of all founders
here's some of the names of billionaires
that produce Jay chaudry net worth 8.3
billion dollar Co Z scaler zenot coachla
Network 5.3 billion former Sun
microsystem co-founder Rome radwani 5.1
billion Rakesh gunwale 4 billion Indigo
CEO founder narij shazio wafer 2.8
billion Anil bursi Network 2.3 billion
CEO workday this is working on how
they're producing and what they're
majoring in now let's look at Family
perspective what do they do that's
different when it comes down to the
family well one thing that's interesting
is it's very common for multiple Indian
families to share a home while building
a business together and continuously
expanding the business so it's almost
like the concept of delayed
gratification hey let's live together
let's minimize expenses let's put all
the money we're making back into the
business rather than splurging and
wasting money all over the place couple
other things to be thinking about when
it comes down to divorce rates did you
know Indian Americans have the lowest
divorce rates in America very
interesting right now some of you are
going to say well of course they have
the lowest divorce rates in America
because they have arranged marriages
they may in India but not necessarily
all in America it does happen but it's
not as high of a number as it is an
Indian has gradually gone away anyways
well let's look at the stats here
according to National Center for Family
and marriage research blacks they have
the highest divorce rate 30.8 percent
Hispanics are 18 and a half whites or
15.1 other is 12.4 but for Indian
families you ready there's some stuff is
that say 1.3 percent and some that show
six percent but they're lower than
anybody else when it comes down to this
obviously uh some of it has to do with
culture ritual all of that but they have
a lower divorce rate than others again
this is purely based on statistics
couple other things we looked at this
website called India
parenting.com and we saw these 10 things
that they do as parenting that's
different than others some of it you may
say I had some of that with my parents
or I apply some of it myself and some of
you may say yeah we definitely don't do
that in America here let me kind of go
through it number one they promote
kinship Indian parents make it a point
for to Foster relationships and
association with their social and family
acquaintances they edify their children
to be in Social connections and also
maintain healthy connections with their
relatives more so they stay as shelter
beside their children till they are
married off right from the children's
infant ages to their marriage times even
after that the parents support their
youngsters emotionally in order to
provide the much needed support ideal
Indian parents created so social
environment where the concept of family
is expanded to all so they're selling
family they're selling kinship they're
selling let's stay close they're
edifying that lifestyle and the kids are
emulating whatever the parent the leader
edifies that's what they want to do
number two self-sacrifice and almost
every Indian parent sacrifices their
lives in some way to devote themselves
and raising their kids Indian mothers
orgo their dreams and passions to take
care of their children fathers often
make compromises in their careers to
ensure well-being of the young ones
interesting everything about life
becomes about pouring into their kids
and look at the types of kids that
they're developed number three
trustworthy and friendly trust is one
thing that Indian parents mostly possess
this Factor makes them the best friend
of their children at least till they're
adulthood Indian mothers become the best
friends their sons while the daughters
love to confine their secrets in their
fathers what let me say that one more
time Indian mothers become best friends
of their sons black daughters feel
comfortable
sharing and confiding
their secrets to their fathers does that
sound American or is it like do you know
what I'm saying very interesting Rob
when you think about the dynamic here of
how this looks let's go to number four
quality time Indian parents amidst their
busy schedule give quality time to their
children they spend great time with
their words instead of just letting them
grow in their own way they're involved
they're not letting them go and let
Society raise their kids they're very
much involved with their kids number
five nurture the talents when it comes
down to Indian parents they're extremely
good at identifying the skills and
unique talents of their children they
told her to enhance those special gifts
that their kids are blessed with you
would often find the Indian kids
teenagers and young adults getting well
acclaimed in a number of creative Fields
thanks to the dedicated and loving
Indian parents number six inquisitive
that's one quality of Indian parents
that many children are annoyed about
very interesting however Indian parents
being curious in nature keep a careful
watch on their kids instead of breaching
the freedom and privacy of their
children parents stay watchful about
their offspring's attitude and behavior
to prevent them from entering into any
misleading paths you know some of the
things you hear parents say leave your
kids alone let them do whatever they
want you know they kind of got to go
through it Indian parents would say
you're a fool to do that when they're
kids you got to be involved so they
don't go out there and do crazy things I
remember well I'm listening to this some
of it's reminding me I'm thinking my
mom's maybe a little bit Indian Middle
Easterns have similar Tendencies by the
way they're on these lists too my sister
went on her first date I'm a younger
brother by six years she says your job
is to spy on her you're gonna go
everywhere she goes so I'm like no
problem yes sir you know it's like yes
ma'am so me and the friends everybody
had a job I watched you from the top
he's here to take care and then boom did
you follow I'm a 14 15 year old kid
we're trying to follow exactly where
this guy's doing watching everything to
come back and report look at that
concept this kid had to do this with his
sister some tells me Indian parents
maybe do a little bit of that as well
sisters are watching the same you would
annoying brother were you I was very
protective power to all the protective
Brothers out there we need more of them
out there I'm hoping will be the same as
well I'm sure they will be okay culture
Indian parents instill the fundamental
culture and religious values into their
children right at their childhood India
is a country that has deep rooted
cultural values its traditions and
Legacies are well maintained Indian
parents make it a point to impart the
same value into their children don't go
away from your values and principles
keep selling the tomb number eight
religious tolerance India is a land of
diversity with multitude of ethnic races
having dissimilar values and Ethos
Indian parents Infuse their Ethics in
their children that let them respect
people hailing from different religions
cast Creeds and racist respect so it's
like hey you got to respect everybody
that's out there make sense number nine
ready this one's going to be a little
bit confusing for some of you judgmental
Indian parents are highly judgmental
that definitely helps them in keeping
their children safe from negatives this
is also one of the best qualities of an
Indian parent to implant the same
insightful abilities in their successors
and last but not least number 10
multitasking most Indians are
hard-working they are diligent when it
comes down to handling their parenting
tasks the moms and ads in India do great
multitasking while managing their
personal and professional life they
strike a fine balance between their
times and dedicate adequate time to both
their children and their jobs alright so
look you may agree with some of the
things you may not agree with some of
the things but the results is there it
shows you the numbers what they've done
and there's a lot to be learned from
what they're doing here's a few
different takeaways number one if your
kids are going to go to school don't
wing it speak to them about what things
to be considered then get involved in
what degrees I watch how involved Tom is
with his kids going and taking degrees
it's amazing seeing parents that are
involved in saying hey look at this look
at that let's research This Together
rather than do whatever you want to do
number two Superior work ethic they
don't compromise their work ethic No
One's Gonna Make them not work hard
including the four hour work week
Business Insider Bloomberg huffle type
of people that are journalists who came
out of Colombia want to convince
everybody to do for their work week good
luck doing that to the Indian Community
and you shouldn't let that happen to you
either number three they're intentional
about what they're doing they're not
winning it they're saying hey here's
what we're doing and this is why this is
what we're doing with our our kids and
here's why there is intention behind the
next vision and discipline extremely
disciplined in how they're raising their
kids based on some of the things that
we're reading here next delayed
gratification is is there and they're
constantly teaching their kids that
there's many ways to do that you know I
can ask my kids sometimes I'll say hey
let me ask you a question would you
rather have me buy you an ice cream
right now but you get no video games for
four weeks or would you rather not have
ice cream for a month but you get four
video games a month from now they're
sitting there oh my God I would much
rather not have to do this I'll wait
versus I have this these are ways to
develop the muscle of delayed
gratification by you putting them in
positions where they have to make the
decision themselves strong values and
they keep selling the values and
principles to their kids and they don't
compromise it they're not embarrassed by
they don't let the world or American
society make them feel guilty about what
they believe in and become softer and
more gentle no this is what we stand for
kid here's who you are here's a family
you're a part of this is what we're
going to be doing now let's figure out
your talents and help you go out there
and do big things within your life and
make us proud make the family proud but
more importantly make you an incredible
net positive to society hey quick shout
out to Indian parents out there I salute
you I respect you for doing what you're
doing you make the world a safer place
by raising kids based on high standards
and high values and principles thank you
for your hard work and dedication
anyways if you got value from this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and I got another video who shot
us a year ago I want to say in Boca how
to raise successful kids if you've never
seen it before click here to watch the
video take care everybody bye-bye
foreign